bodies lie in the Gloom of a Ukrainian
blackout the collateral damage of
Russia's latest Onslaught against
Ukraine's power grid and Onslaught
civilians would be forgiven for feeling
is directed specifically at them
nearly 70 missiles and drones were
launched says Ukraine's leadership 51 of
them downed imagine the destruction if
more had got through
the EU Parliament declared Russia a
state sponsor of terrorism today
finally I'm grateful to all the European
parliamentarians then Russia proved it
true to the whole world launching 67
rockets at our infrastructure at our
energy at regular civilians the result
is tragic
president zielinski insists Engineers
are working flat out to get power and
water back up again but they've got an
enormous task ahead pretty much every
city across this large country has a
Skyline as dark as this one on Wednesday
night from Kiev to kharkiv from danipro
to Odessa people are shivering in their
candlelit homes and the temperature has
dropped below zero
it was a day that began with death too
this was a maternity unit on the
outskirts of zaparizia until Russian
missiles arrived a newborn baby was
killed the mother and two doctors barely
survived
she said a missile hit the maternity
hospital and she could not find her
child she was pulled up from under the
rubble by the emergency workers her
child was dead
people here believe that Russia losing
ground to Ukraine's military is trying
to break civilian will instead but
despite the death and discomfort they
insist they won't be broken Rory
challenge Al Jazeera Kiev